بادئ ذي بدء، أتحدث كمواطن إسرائيلي كمواطن
أمريكي كشخص
يراقب كل ما
يحدث من خلال تجربتي التي
نشأت في إسرائيل وأيضًا
كعالم سياسي يدرس
ويبحث في هذه القضايا
لسنوات عديدة  الآن أم من هؤلاء من كل
تلك وجهات النظر المختلفة أمم توصلت
إلى هذا الإدراك أو أو أننا توصلنا
إلى هذا القرار بأن هذا أم آه أراه
هو حقًا الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكن من خلالها تحقيق أي حل أه أم أعتقد
أن أي أه  العنف المستمر
الذي يولد العنف الذي يولد
العنف أه لن يؤدي إلا إلى إبعادنا
عن حل
الصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي أه وكما تعلمون
أنه من المهم حقًا أن نتذكر
أننا كنا نسمع أيضًا من
صانعي السياسات من صانعي السياسة الأمريكيين و
حتى من صانعي السياسة الإسرائيليين
والخبراء العسكريين أنه لا يوجد
حل عسكري للصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
وإذا لم يكن هناك
حل عسكري للصراع فلا توجد
طريقة عسكرية للقضاء على حماس أه
كذلك كلما زاد الضرر الذي نلحقه كلما
زاد العنف الذي يحدث
أه أيًا كان ما يريده أي شخص أه
كخلفية إما لتبرير ذلك أو
لشرحه، فهذا ليس له معنى بالنسبة
للمستقبل، فهو فقط يجعلنا
بعيدًا عن إيجاد هذا الحل من
القدرة على التحرك نحو الناس
حيث أن السكان يغيرون
التركيبة السكانية تتغير اه اه
البنية التحتية تتغير على مدى
كل هذه السنوات من الاحتلال الذي
لا يمكن أه مواصلة إدارة
الصراع التي كانت سياسة
الحكومة الإسرائيلية أه على الأقل منذ
2009 لم تكن أبدا  للعمل أه
وليس له المدى الطويل أه ولا احتمال طويل المدى